[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa este es el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
nicaragua cortó sus vínculos
diplomáticos con taiwán que hasta ahora
era uno de sus mayores donantes y socios
comerciales
taipei y washington lamentaron la
decisión que aseguran refleja la falta
de compromisos de daniela ortega con la
democracia
y ya es legal en chile el matrimonio
entre parejas del mismo sexo el
presidente sebastián piñera promulgó la
ley que permite las uniones entre los
homosexuales y las lesbianas y la
adopción y filiación de sus hijos y eeuu
reactivó el programa quédate en mexico
que obliga a los solicitantes de asilo a
permanecer en territorio mexicano hasta
que se resuelva su petición
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal en medio de
cuestionamientos de la comunidad
internacional sobre su legitimidad y su
gobierno el presidente de nicaragua
daniel ortega reconoció que china y
taiwán son una sola nación y que el
gobierno legítimo de la isla es el de
chilling ping taiwán reclama desde
1949 su soberanía managua mantenía
buenas relaciones con la isla desde 1990
y de hecho se había convertido en su
principal donante así como un importante
socio comercial de hecho la ruptura se
da poco después de que el gobierno de
ortega condecorará al embajador de
taiwán en su país y le entregara las
llaves de la ciudad
la cancillería de taiwán lamentó que se
ignorarán años de amistad y cooperación
mientras que el presidente de eeuu joe
biden aseguró que la decisión de ortega
no refleja la voluntad del pueblo
nicaragüense haciendo a la vez
referencia a los cuestionamientos a los
resultados de las elecciones del 7 de
noviembre en las que ortega en unos
comicios sin participación de la
oposición ya que al menos siete
precandidatos fueron arrestados y otros
más obligados a exiliarse ni veeduría
internacional fue reelecto para un
cuarto mandato consecutivo veamos más en
el informe de jorge hurtado
un giro de 180 grados de forma
sorpresiva el gobierno de nicaragua
rompió relaciones diplomáticas con
taiwán uno de sus principales donantes
extranjeros y con quién hablar dio años
de buenas relaciones y cooperación
bilateral el gobierno de la república de
nicaragua
declara que reconoce que en el mundo
sólo existe una sola china'
la república popular china es el único
gobierno legítimo que representa a toda
china y taiwán es parte inalienable del
territorio chino según datos oficiales
tan solo en 2020 taiwán donó 28 millones
de dólares al sector público
nicaragüense hasta ahora el país
centroamericano era uno de los 17 países
del mundo que reconocían a taiwán que es
considerado por china una provincia
rebelde desde mediados del siglo pasado
el gobierno de la república de nicaragua
rompe a partir de hoy las relaciones
diplomáticas con taiwán y deja de tener
cualquier contacto o relación oficial
pero minutos después del anuncio de
managua la televisión china difundió
imágenes de una delegación nicaragüense
liderada por dos hijos de daniel ortega
reunidos con autoridades chinas en una
ciudad cercana a beijing taiwán era
además un importante socio comercial en
los últimos meses las exportaciones de
nicaragua taiwán representaron más de 60
millones de dólares y unos 25 millones
en importaciones
taiwán lamentó la ruptura de relaciones
diplomáticas con nicaragua y catalogó
como un desprecio a los años de amistad
el gobierno de daniel ortega restablece
las relaciones con china cuando está
aislado por la comunidad internacional y
distanciado de la organización de
estados americanos oea que le exige la
liberación de más de 150 presos
políticos y cuestiona las últimas
elecciones presidenciales
nicaragua se suma ahora a países de la
región como panamá y el salvador que
rompieron con taiwán para alinearse con
la cooperación china
y vamos a chile para revisar la imagen
de la semana el congreso aprobó el
proyecto que legaliza el matrimonio el
gmt y qu más y miles de parejas lo
celebraron a las afueras del legislativo
en valparaíso el presidente sebastián
piñera promulgó la ley esta misma semana
que permite además la adopción y
filiación por parte de parejas
homoparentales veamos más en el
siguiente informe
los aplausos estallan dentro del
parlamento chileno mientras los
legisladores aprueban el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo
primero tras recibir la luz verde del
senado la cámara de diputados votó
abrumadoramente a favor de un cambio en
la ley con 82 votos a favor y 20 en
contra es una jornada histórica
relevante y da cuenta de una conquista
civilizatoria que es el resultado de
años de lucha y de esfuerzo con objeto
de no solo modificar la ley sino que
cambiar la cultura el proyecto de ley
fue presentado por primera vez al
congreso en 2017 por la ex presidenta
michelle bachelet y aunque durante los
últimos cuatro años ha encontrado con la
resistencia del partido conservador
gobernante el proyecto de ley recibió
una mayoría de votos a favor en cada
paso del proceso en un congreso dominado
por la oposición
el presidente sebastián piñera quien
dejara el cargo en marzo lo promulgó
todas las parejas que así lo deseen
independiente de su orientación sexual
podrán vivir el amor contraer matrimonio
y formar familia con toda la dignidad y
protección legal que sin duda necesitan
y merecen
hasta ahora las parejas del mismo sexo
podían registrar una unión civil pero
ahora podrán casarse y adoptar hijos
y la esperanza para los migrantes que
buscan llegar a méxico huyendo de la
violencia en sus países de origen fue
destruida esta semana debido a que eeuu
reinstauró una política de la era camps
que los obliga a permanecer en la nación
azteca mientras se esperan que sus
solicitudes de asilo sean resueltas el
presidente joe biden había tratado de
eliminar el plan bautizado como quédate
en mexico como parte de su objetivo de
tener un enfoque más humano hacia el
problema migratorio pero la corte
federal ordenó re imponerla en respuesta
a una demanda de las autoridades de
texas y misurí la decisión contrasta con
la alegría que se vivía en la frontera
entre tijuana y california con la
reapertura para personas completamente
evacuadas hace unos días veamos más en
el informe de nuestros corresponsales en
terreno
el puesto fronterizo más grande entre
eeuu y méxico
vuelve a funcionar a capacidad total el
de tijuana más de 100.000 turistas
cruzan la frontera todos los días muchos
mexicanos van a hacer compras en el otro
lado ropas zapatos marcas compras de
tiendas que no hay acá en méxico hicimos
la cola super larga pero hicimos dos
horas es lo mismo que se hacía antes las
largas filas no molestan en absoluto a
los vendedores ambulantes víctor es
originario del sur de méxico pero se
mudó a tijuana para ganarse la vida
durante unos años volvió a vender
churros en la frontera es una entrada
más de dinero a comparación de una
maquila ahorita ya como de la apertura
de la frontera pues ya es un poquito más
la el fluido y más un poco de más
ganancias para nosotros la reapertura de
la frontera también permite que la
familia se reencuentren después de una
larga separación vamos a visitar a una
hermana
de dos años que no la miramos vamos a ir
a verla apenas llevo a mis papás a mi
mamá para que la vean también pero los
migrantes no comparten esta emoción en
la frontera
este refugio alberga 72 personas la
mayoría mexicanos esperando para entrar
a los eeuu en los últimos meses el padre
patricio recibió cada vez a más personas
diariamente llegué a gente buscando
gente buscando asilo y tenemos que dar
la mala noticia y que así lo no existe
en este momento
eeuu sigue deportando migrantes bajo el
título 42 una medida que tomó donald
trump cuando comenzó la pandemia
ros amargo sus dos hijos pagaron el
precio salieron del estado de michoacán
amenazados por un grupo delictivo cuando
solicitaron asilo en los estados unidos
las autoridades los descartaron duramos
un día cuando al día siguiente nos sacan
título 42 están nadamas discriminando o
sea los que están pidiendo ayuda eso sí
pueden contagiar los y a los que van a
ir a invertir dinero ellos no
la familia ha estado aquí durante tres
meses y no tiene más remedio que esperar
una flexibilización de las políticas
estadounidenses esperemos volver a
pedirle ayuda y volver a intentarlo para
que se nos pueda otorgar la por lo menos
el chance de que nos escuchen por ahora
el título 42 mantiene a raya todas las
esperanzas para los migrantes la
frontera está cerrada para ellos están
vacunados o no no sabemos cuándo para
abrir ya hacemos
manifestaciones protestas escribimos
cartas viene el vaivén que tomó alguna
decisión coge la gente que eran
decisiones dado que los flujos
migratorios han alcanzado niveles récord
en el continente estados unidos reinició
el programa quédate en mexico que se
prevé regresar a miles de personas
solicitantes de asilo a territorio
mexicano
vamos ahora a revisar la cifra de la
semana 900 ese es el número de personas
que fueron despedidas por una compañía
en la misma videollamada de zoom el
director de la empresa birdair puntocom
que es una compañía de hipotecas anunció
los recortes en la temporada de
festividades de fin de año sin decoro
posteriormente se disculpó
y la provincia de quebec en canadá
ordenó liberar sus reservas de miel de
maple la única en el mundo en medio de
la escasez de esta salsa dulce para los
pancakes una cosecha difícil sumada a
los problemas mundiales en la cadena de
suministro está causando esta crisis
para el desayuno
el encuentro inesperado entre la
pandemia y el cambio climático nos lleva
aquí a la reserva global estratégica de
miel de maple las normas de
confinamiento hicieron que la demanda se
disparara pero un invierno
inesperadamente corto ha reducido la
cosecha de este año el néctar del norte
está hecho de la savia de árboles de
arce que fluye solo cuando las
temperaturas de congelación y
descongelación alternan entre la noche y
el día con el fin de mantener la oferta
en línea con la demanda la asociación de
productores de quebec está poniendo en
el mercado más de 22 millones de kilos
de su jarabe para los días de lluvia la
organización y su reserva estratégica a
menudo se compara con la opep el
organismo petrolero mundial esto
evidencia que para quebec que produce
cerca de las tres cuartas partes del
suministro mundial de jarabe de arce es
un negocio serio
y
representa a 800 millones de dólares
desde el pib de canadá
más de 12.000 personas en quebec que
trabajan en esta industria
y más allá del hecho de que las árabe de
arce ahora se exporta a más de 60 países
alrededor del mundo es parte de nuestra
cultura
la industria está fuertemente regulada
con un sistema de cuotas centralizado
para administrar la producción y
mantener los precios altos pero los
patrones climáticos cada vez más
variables podrían tener un impacto en la
producción durante los próximos años y
la industria tendrá que adaptarse
hoy en día la tecnología nos permite
obtener más savia de los árboles de arce
todo comienza con la madre naturaleza
y aunque con nuestra tecnología podemos
garantizar una mayor rentabilidad la
congelación y descongelación de la savia
es esencial para el proceso
mientras tanto la asociación ha aprobado
7 millones de nuevos grifos para
impulsar la producción durante los
próximos tres años y que más personas
puedan disfrutar del manjar en sus
pancakes
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
giovanni agudelo para más información de
nuestro continente pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas y seguir viendo
france24
[Música]
mama